during a storm we are at war with Mother
Nature these avalanches can be deadly
and the best way to mitigate them is
with explosives here at Mammoth Mountain
it's a blast from the past we literally
use World War 2 cannons
my name is Matt Seibert mammoth mountain
ski patroller on any given day if we can
see anywhere between 5,000 and 18,000
guests we try to keep a constant watch
on the mountain and changing conditions
to create the safest environment
possible
[Music]
steep slopes large snowfall intense
winds are all recipes for an avalanche
[Music]
I've worked in our artillery program
here at Mammoth Mountain for the past
seven years dalit sir was originally a
World War 2 weapon of war now
discontinued in the war theater is now a
valuable tool for avalanche mitigation
our whole team feels secure when the gun
goes out and fires it's able to reach
targets that we would not normally be
able to reach with just throwing hand
charges our intent is to create many
small controlled avalanches as opposed
to letting the snow rest and winding up
with one large devastating avalanche we
fire our gun 90% of the time blind in a
storm without being able to see our
target we are capable of dialing in on
one tiny little rock and nailing it on
the nose the risks are real each day we
arrive at work we put our name on the
board for accountability
we go out together we work together at
the end of the day we come in together
take our name off the board and we don't
stop work until the last one of us is in
for the day
I do take joy knowing that there are
families out here recreative having fun
bringing up the next generation of
skiers and snowboarders enjoying the
mountain it's a job I love and it's my
goal to create the safest environment
for our guests
[Music]